in the next set of videos forming unit
three of your course our goal is to
discuss how sell harvest energy from
fuel molecules and also to show that at
the most fundamental level the eggs egg
anak transfer of electrons through a
series of protein complexes powers the
endergonic synthesis of ATP in this
video I would like to give you a quick
overview of key pathways leading to the
synthesis of ATP so don't worry about
the specifics for now we have plenty of
time for that later
based on my introduction to concept
emerge first molecules have to give
electron and second some molecule have
to receive these electrons let's
identify what are the electron donating
and accepting processes first in the
electron donating process fuel molecules
will pass the electrons to a small
number of universal electron acceptors
such as nad plus or Fe D the electron
accepting process is when you have a
flow of electrons from these fewer
Universal electron acceptor to a final
electron acceptor which is on this
diagram oxygen let's take a look at the
major part of the energetic pathways in
Arabic organisms first we start with
glycolysis that convert glucose into
pyruvate this oxidation of glucose is
done by a series of steps some of which
are coupled with the synthesis of ATP in
these steps molecule with a hydrolysis
potential will transfer their phosphate
to ADP to form ATP
this type of ATP synthesis is called
substrate level phosphorylation in
addition of producing pyruvate and ATP
the electrons that are produced by the
oxidation of glucose are passed to nad
to form NADH the second pathway is the
citric acid cycle during glycolysis
glucose is not fully oxidized so
pyruvate react with coenzyme a to form
acetyl coenzyme a and the acetyl group
will feed the citric acid cycle to
complete the oxidation of glucose the
major role of the citric acid cycle is
to form a large quantity of this
universal electron acceptor nadh and
fadh2 one step in the citric acid cycle
is also coupled with the synthesis of
GTP by substrate level phosphorylation
subsequently GTP will be converted into
ATP these two pathway are part of the
electron donating process now what about
the actual accepting process it is the
third part of the bulkan called pathway
that interests us the electrons stored
in nadh and fadh2 are passed through a
series of protein complex forming the
electron transport chain this transfer
of electron relieves energy that will
lead to the synthesis of ATP by the ATP
synthase in this case this type of ATP
synthesis is called oxidative
phosphorylation under some conditions
aerobic organisms or tissues from
aerobic organisms will operate under
anaerobic conditions so NADH cannot be
converted back into nad because
oxidative phosphorylation is not working
the necessary conversion of NADH to NAD+
is made possible by a series of pathway
that are collectively called
fermentation so that is for organisms
that have to live in the presence of
oxygen aerobic organisms so what is the
situation for anaerobic organism they
can produce ATP through glycolysis and
in some cases through fermentation but
ATP synthesis powered by the electron
transport chain is possible as well
anaerobic organisms use diverse
mechanisms to harvest energy from fuel
molecules they can transfer electrons
from a variety of electron donors to a
variety of electron acceptors other than
oxygen for example
denitrifying bacteria use an electron
acceptor nitrate that is converted into
dinitrogen this conversion is coupled
with the transfer of electrons that will
power the synthesis of ATP don't think
that glucose is the only electron
donating fuel molecules in fact cells
are remarkably good at harvesting
electrons from diverse fuel molecules
for example in aerobic organisms
amino acids and fatty acids are
converted into acetyl coenzyme a that
will feed the citric acid cycle and need
to the surfaces of a large number of
molecule of ATP through oxidative
phosphorylation
in conclusion all the pathways leading
to the ATP synthesis are collectively
referred to as cellular respiration if
the final electron acceptor is oxygen
this process will be called aerobic
respiration if the electron acceptor is
something else than oxygen for example
nitrate in the case of denitrifying
bacteria this type of respiration is
called anaerobic respiration the rest of
the video from unit 3 will focus on a
detailed analysis of the biochemical
pathways leading to the synthesis of ATP